you know we
saw bridesmaids and we were like we love
the gross parts we wanted to be
more like the hangover and less like
more girls we have to talk about our
feelings and relationships
basically we knew we wanted to produce
something we knew we needed better
material that made it down
and we had this like one really crazy
night
where our dynamics were just our dynamic
was just so
on display and we decided to like steal
several of the moments from that night
and write about them yeah
and we just had this idea where it was
like
sometimes sketch comedy it hits the same
beat a little too often but i think
our generation and like how we watch
content
it's like you can see a joke once and
you're like okay that's good it's true
you don't watch
past you know 40 seconds anymore really
i mean why don't why not capitalize on
our
like you know current situation
and life like when something awkward
happens to you doesn't happen three
times it's like oops
right so i don't know that's fair we're
just like following we call them two
episodes for a while because they're
like
twitter episodes not quite but all of
them are real things like i even said
i was like you have to come out to new
york so i can take off work and we can
go out every night
because when we're together the
disasters that happen
you can't even remember yeah
that's true they did a couple of big
network pitch meetings like temple
generals
to pitch the hotness brand and
the thing that they keep getting told in
these meetings is
this content is great but it's not
network like a network will never buy
this
it's too risque it's too crude
it's never going to work on tv it's ever
going to work with a network
and so that's frustrating to them
because they are speaking
to your everyday girl next door
that has a that makes mistakes is a hot
mess from time to time
isn't that tricky transition between
college and the real world and trying to
find a job
and being broke and this is just real
life experiences that everyone
um you know faces and and there's
there's got to be an audience for that
people have to be able to relate to that
because it
it is just relatable is what it is
and so yeah tv might not understand it
yet
but the web definitely will um
and so that's where we're starting and
you know hopefully
just go from there you learn
that's a great question i think it
really is we always describe it as like
yin and yang
like everybody's always like i can't
believe why i'm actually
friends all of it separately it doesn't
really make that much sense
when you see it she's so confident and
i'm so neurotic i need her
to like pretend that i'm confident and i
need her to like
balance me out when she moved away i got
these like boils
under my skin i was so stressed out the
perfect example is that
i started seeing a hypnotist to cure my
panic attacks and i
made her go that's how i help
you are that but yes so like we balance
each other out like that
i don't know anybody else that can
ground me like lyle does and make me
self-reflect
and be like you know what maybe that
isn't a right thing to say right now
if people in general should just get a
little bit more honest about
what [ __ ] ups they are i think everybody
would feel
a lot better like my dad's a therapist
and he was like
he was like i was i told him i was like
i feel like a faker and he's like that's
why i make so much money
and he doesn't make money anyway but
where am i going
um but i i don't know i think that
there's all this [ __ ] we all pretend
to be these like really put together
people especially women like you're not
allowed to
make dick jokes that are like boys are
allowed to be [ __ ] ups and still be
successful
i feel like women have to lock it up a
lot and like that
it doesn't matter at all i mean it
really is it's
it is women's central when people want
to be like you put us in a box we've
you know heard other women series or
like you can replace them with guys and
it's the same thing
you can't replace us with nothing like
these are women's
issues that you have to deal with if
it's throw code yeah it's like
you can't go out you know doing certain
things because
other you know like you can't go to a
job interview and like a t-shirt and
jeans just to like
prove your point you've got to wear
heels you know these are women's rules
but you know there's a reason why we
have them
foreign